I've been watching my daughter's life on
like a phone and it's a little like what
am I doing like she's never going to be
six again you know and I missed like
tons of her
life and I'm just like yeah I make this
money but I'm like I've watched my kids
life do a fing FaceTime dude I saw that
clip man I fell in love with you on that
uh me and B we having a great time
talking about just comedy and then I
don't know what the hell happened but we
started talking about our kids and then
I started to have like this Epiphany
live on his show about like how much
time I'm missing in my kids life and I'm
like I don't want to do that he said I'm
making tons of money but at the cost of
not seeing my kids grow up and you
started to cry and like it was kind of a
bad look for Bert If we're honest
because he's just sort of like laughing
at you not even understanding like any
importance whatsoever for watching your
children grow up yeah yeah